lance lynn back from uh sore knee and
this year
24 previous starts looking for his 11th
win as era a touch above two and a half
a lot of strikeouts very few walks and
he's been really good this year so i'm
sure the sox would love to get five
that's what he's going to use it's
almost entirely fastballs although he
uses a lot of variations of it
hernandez will
step up
check swing he went strike three one
gone
i don't need no appeal on that one
really good way to start it off on a
sweeping breaking ball we'll call it a
cutter for a lack of a better term and
kiki could not check it up you want to
face schwarber today as many times as
possible with nobody on banks
he did get in on schwarber
and there with garcia he's out number
two this is the lancelin white sox fans
wanted to see in the early
going high pop fly shallow left jimenez
comes in and makes the grab
and the red sox go quietly in the top of
the first nice work nick pavetta is back
off the cover 19 il as of today
looking for his first victory since
august 13. robert he was four for five
good help alex cora is certainly hoping
so here comes renfro a bit of a late
start but jumps up to make the play one
gone makata adds second
that's a beauty 96 on the black good
luck wow there it is again
that paint do this all day long he's
always had tough first innings not here
back to back paint balls jimenez 266
with eight home runs runner at second
two down
and slapped to short and glaciers up and
over
and pavetta gets out of it he's off
single by grandahl
bouncer dulbeck digs it got one and got
two double play on the stretch nice job
all the way around by bobby at first
base those are not easy double plays
it's all about the throw and we're
talking about defense bobby's been doing
excellent on the defensive side here as
of late
just picking it
look at that stretch
nice throw good feed and he gets back to
first base devers airs it out
had to
garcia was getting down that line
sheetz he's a 223 hitter with eight home
runs
cut on and missed not so comfortable on
that one not a good yakker from pavetta
faces only three men in the end six up
six down for lance lynn and travis shaw
at the plate
down he goes one gone
hey strike three with that finish for
lance that's a two-part finish as you
see it starts with the hand in the air
let's watch it again he wanted a
fastball in the outside corner got it
there and that was it four strikeouts no
walks finally threw the ball away not
exactly four-part harmony but two-part
finish so first base runner for the red
sox
struck him out three strikeouts in the
inning that fastball was an illusion
hernandez great to see lance lynn
working the way he has nearly all season
for the white sox
ducey strike three eighth strikeout for
lance lin this stuff has been
outstanding the location has been
actually better than the stuff and so
far lance is he's just getting it done
he's getting the ball he's throwing it
pavetta is doing the same thing for
boston i mean he's getting it he's
throwing it throwing mostly strikes this
has been quite a pitchers duel early in
this game
another strikeout for lance lynn
sebby wanted a breaking ball and lance
said i think i'm gonna go with the
fastball just off the corner he cuts it
just a touch
this ball moving away from dull back and
no chance
one on two out for plawecki
first base side grandahl
over the shoulder how about that nice
play so nick into his fifth inning
and a leaping catch by iglesias on the
right side yeah a little snow cone but
he hauls it in stuck in there the ball's
hot wow granddad's been swinging a hot
bat he's hitting everything
robert and center coasting back he has
room
iglesias tags and he is in there did he
come off the back yes he did
the anchor didn't work that's a huge
mistake and luis robert didn't have the
chance to really set up to get
everything he needed to get in that
throw and yet it got there it got there
pretty quickly
now iglesias takes a few steps realizes
that robert is going to catch it
backpedaling
he's able to plant a bit he got it there
and then tumbles off the bag and a good
job by hernandez keeping the tag on him
yeah he got the hand right there then he
got the leg he got everything that uh
that looked like a lawn dart for a
second he tried to do
he tried to do a javi bias
instead i'm not sure exactly what that
was but he just went by it yeah he was a
bias okay
bye-bye luis has got to try to attack
him early and drive home the first run
of the ball game cesar at second one
gone
into left field base hit schwarber just
got to it cesar is on his way home
throwing a second not in time
robert doubles in iran it's the first
run and it's one nothing he got him
early and he got him before he could get
the two strikes took it through the left
side and even though cesar
was stopped because he wanted to make
sure that it didn't go through he made
sure it got through
it wasn't hitting anybody and then took
off and realized that as deep as
schwarber was
there was no way they could get him at
the plate also he had to go far to his
right
joe mcewing says keep on going no chance
to get him at the plate and on the back
end on the throw it's a single he
advanced on the throw and it's one and
nothing he didn't make an argument that
he might have gotten a second base
anyway they'll call it an rbi single one
nothing sucks regardless that's what
matters 12 got home pivetta is leaving
and the sox have a one-nothing lead
xander bogarts is going to pinch hit for
kevin palwecki's
second base
cesar two goal
ruiz three straight outs on balls in
play
sharply hit ground or right to the
shortstop garcia up with it he gets him
jose ruiz
four up four down
and a one two three
eighth inning he came down to third
renfro at second devers at first for
verdugo who is over three
he swings it's a high fly ball into left
field backing up jimenez
[ __ ] back to tag here he comes
he races in to score and the red sox are
on the board and they have tied the ball
game 1-1 they did it again two out for
garcia the 02 garcia center field purdue
go back who needs a 10th inning
sox win
2-1
on two strikes a little unlikely thunder
off the bat of
how about the boys around home plate